[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the samsung galaxy s5 so right off
the bat we can see this phone looks
really similar to the galaxy s4 from
last year it has upgraded specs inside
of course which are virtually identical
to the one m8 except for one or two
things but it keeps a very similar
design to the galaxy s4 though it is a
little bit bigger now to fit that 5.1
inch 1080p display and slightly bigger
bezels so awkwardly enough one of the
biggest complaints with the new design
is about the backing which a lot of
people aren't a fan of i mean i called
it i call the gold version of this phone
the band-aid edition but basically it
has all these little dimples across the
back of this soft touch material turns
out this is easier to grip and hold in
the hand than the slippery metal of the
htc one m8 so while the m8 might be a
little bit heavier and made entirely of
metal the s5 is easier to hold because
it's lighter
and the button placement is much better
you got the power button on the side now
so you don't have to shimmy your hand
and it has actual sides to grip even
though those sides are made of samsung's
fake metal oh and the back happens to
still be removable so you get not only
micro sd card expansion up to 128 extra
gigabytes but you also get access to
that 2800 milliamp hour battery and
something you might notice while taking
that back off is this seal all the way
around the inside of the cover of this
phone this is to make the internals or
the whole phone ip67 certified so ip67
the six means totally protected against
dust and the seven means water resistant
for limited periods of time which is
useful to some people
but you'll notice the seal does not go
over the speaker which sounds alright
but it maxes out pretty low in volume
compared to the htc one but i guess you
know everything is quiet compared to the
one so the full video comparison between
the s5 and the one are coming soon but
bottom line is this thing is water
resistant and a lot of people are gonna
like that but also to protect the phone
from dust and water they needed to add
probably my biggest gripe with the
design of the entire phone this freaking
flap at the bottom that you have to pry
off every time you want access to the
usb port every time you want to charge
it that means you can't use any battery
cases because you have to pry that thing
out the way all the time it just gets in
the way when you're plugged in and to
top it all off every time you unplug the
phone from the wall it reminds you to
close the flap every
single time bottom line i'm not a fan of
the flap although i guess it is
necessary to keep that certification but
other than that this is really a
familiar design for anyone who's used
previous galaxy devices especially the
galaxy s4 and you'll notice they've
changed the capacitive buttons up front
so now really the only face change
besides the bigger bezels is you have
that multitasking button and back button
so you can hold down the multitasking
button to act as a mini button and right
between those capacitive buttons is the
fingerprint sensor slash home button
i'm basically going to cover everything
by saying it's not really that great
first of all it makes the home button a
little bit mushier and less clicky than
before and second of all much more
importantly you have to swipe your
finger perfectly vertically along the
center of the pad for it to work you
don't just put your finger there you
have to swipe it perfectly vertically
for it to work so yes you can register a
bunch of fingerprints and secure your
phone or your paypal payments or
whatever you want to do and it'll work
if you take your time with it but it's
difficult to use correctly and it's not
always accurate when you don't swipe
your finger at just the right speed at
the right angle which does by the way
require holding the phone with one hand
and swiping with the other so you need
two fingers to unlock your phone and
sometimes i'd actually go to unlock my
phone with the fingerprint on and it
would work and then i'd unlock it a
little bit later and it just wouldn't
even work it doesn't even ask just lets
me swipe to unlock and get in without my
fingerprint uh and that was it so yeah i
turned off the fingerprint recognition
stuff before the end of the first day i
used it
really was a pain but anyway once you
unlock the phone and get in you are
greeted with touchwiz on top of android
4.4 and it's all right it's definitely
not my cup of tea it's not my favorite
but i prefer it to previous versions
they definitely made some adjustments
and cleaned it up and made changes that
i like i know they've shaken that uh
inspired by nature stuff from touchwiz
on the galaxy s3 but they still have
these nature sound effects these bloop
and noises that i've disabled had to
disable them pretty much immediately for
my own sanity i wish they would clean up
the sounds and actually i think that
would have a surprisingly big effect on
how you perceive the user interface but
other than that thanks to the specs the
s5 is pretty quick it's responsive there
isn't really any lag in most places but
when you do find lag like in the gallery
for example it's bad like i mean for a
high-end flagship phone with monster
specs like this the phone really does
have the slowest gallery so when you do
find lag you'll notice it but touchwiz
is pretty much exactly as you'd expect
colorful
big bold and constantly pushing samsung
features one of those samsung features
being my magazine which is the pain that
sits to the left of your home screens
like blinkfeed or google now and it's
kind of this news aggregator like
blinkfeed and just talks to flipboard
basically pulls in some cool stories
very beautiful imagery and uses the
entire 5.1 inch display
uh i mean it does what it's supposed to
it's just a matter of whether you want
it there or not also it can't be
disabled or hidden like blinkfeed can
now another notable thing here is the
settings menu actually i i thought it
was in my galaxy s4 review that i
mentioned that samsung really needs to
change the way they organize their
settings basically because there were so
many and they needed a search box but
this is absolutely not what i meant i
didn't mean put them all in a grid of 60
something colorful icons that i have to
scroll through to find what i want holy
crap there are just way too many for
that so i maintain
samsung should really find a better way
to handle all of the device settings
than this there's a grid view there's a
list view either way there are just too
many uh but yeah i don't know i guess
touchwiz just isn't my favorite uh
plenty of people will not have a problem
with it at all obviously if you've used
a galaxy s3 or you've used a galaxy s4
and you like it this experience here
will be very similar
and there are other plenty of new useful
features the editable quick notification
settings are really useful there's also
feature called toolbox that lets you
store any five apps in this bubble that
you can move around and it gives you
quick access from that bubble to those
apps anywhere so no matter where you are
you just tap it and it brings up your
favorite app list it's nifty i actually
left that on and use it for a quite a
bit so these are the types of things
that will get you to
like the phone more and even if the
things that you like aren't enabled by
default you'll probably find something
buried in the settings somewhere that
you can turn on and make it a much more
enjoyable user experience now i
mentioned at the beginning of the video
that the galaxy s5 has basically
identical specs to the one m8 except for
a few key areas
one of those key areas is sitting on the
back here of this phone you'll notice
this lens protrudes from the body a bit
it's that 16 megapixel camera this
camera is excellent and i'll immediately
go on record and say it's one of the top
five smartphone cameras you can get
right now it is very very good now maybe
it's because i spent too much time with
the four megapixel camera on the one m8
but basically the shots i'm taking i'm
noticing a few key characteristics again
here one very very detailed tons of
resolution and detail at 16 megapixels
and two they're very saturated photos
and colorful in pretty much any
conditions so the camera interface is
pretty standard samsung stuff not you
know too overly simple you know samsung
likes to give you a ton of options
there's lots of effects and things you
can play with and change you can take 4k
video you have software stabilization
you have hdr the whole deal you have
something here also called selective
focus which again might ring a bell from
the one m8 it's done a little bit
differently here basically it instructs
you to take a photo of something close
with an out of focus background and it
takes a pair of photos for you one that
focuses on the foreground and one that
focuses on the background but lets you
pick between them using just one button
for near focus or far focus but what i
really liked was actually the pan focus
button which actually lets you grab
everything in focus at the same time
which can actually be really useful and
let you get a whole shot a whole
composition right through some software
processing so here we have another
version you can see near focus far focus
and then pan focus obviously it's not
perfect and it's a pretty artificial
effect but the ability to switch the
stuff on the fly on your phone with a
single button press is pretty neat i
think a lot of people like that so
basically i found myself taking a lot
more pictures with the galaxy s5 just
because of how good the camera looks how
good the pictures look on the phone so
there's an awesome display combined with
a 16 megapixel shot and that really lets
you grab detail from the smallest things
and blow them up the images look really
razor sharp now obviously if you zoom in
a ton you'll see smaller imperfections
and blurs but this stuff you'll have
trouble doing on pretty much any other
smartphone camera 16 megapixels gives
you a lot of room to play with it's not
41 it's not 50 but you guys know i love
pixels and it's awesome to see this much
detail and color in a quick shot like
this and the ability to shoot 4k video
is a sweet bonus so nice job on the
camera samsung but hold up a minute what
is below the camera what is going on
there that is not an extra depth sensor
or anything fancy for imaging
that is actually a heart rate monitor
yeah a special hardware to measure your
heart rate obviously s health is still a
thing that samsung does so they've
plugged into that sensor on the back of
the phone and essentially if you hold
your finger there for a few seconds
it'll give you a reading of your heart
rate in beats per minute now i don't
actually know how accurate this is
because i don't have another heart rate
sensor to control but it's a neat
feature it's a neat demo to bolster the
s health uh portfolio of things it can
do it's a pedometer and hurry monitor
whatever it's s health so anyway yeah if
you're not getting the picture by now
basically the galaxy s5 is an
improvement in a lot of ways over the
galaxy s4 uh and a lot of smartphone
enthusiasts tend to see that as i guess
a bad thing because they really didn't
like the galaxy s4 or they were
expecting a bigger change but for the
many millions of people who will
inevitably buy this phone that's
actually great the galaxy s4 was a solid
phone and this phone improves on it in a
lot of important ways so so what if this
phone looks like a band-aid in gold get
it in black or get it in white get it in
blue you know it's great it's a high-end
phone with a ton of features it's water
resistant it has an excellent battery
life that nobody should have any
problems with it has a beautiful large
colorful bright display easily the best
amoled display in the business on a
smartphone right now it's lightweight
it's made of some cheap materials sure
but you're coming from the s4 so you're
probably not going to notice and really
the only real downside i have with
touchwiz is or with the galaxy s5 is
touchwiz and it's quirks and i guess the
speaker a little bit too but touchwiz
will continue to evolve
and right now the galaxy s5 really is
the galaxy s4 s that i called it in my
first impressions video so don't mind me
i'm just going to sit back over here and
quietly cross my fingers waiting for a
google play edition of this phone
because the new google camera came out
today and it's great and i like stock
android and i feel like i would really
enjoy a google play edition galaxy s5
but in the meantime there it is this is
the samsung galaxy s5 thanks for
watching guys and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
[Music]
you